[Music]
going to try to do this tip where you
can kind of see what I'm doing here a
lot of people when they are weeding a
garden they let it get out of
control and then they go in and they
have to spend hours weeding it and kind
of a trick that I've been doing for
years I only take 10 minutes every day I
come out into the garden I look at an
area that's got some weeds and I spend
10 minutes just cleaning up those little
bit of
weeds and because I do that every
day the weeds don't get out of control
and it's pretty easy to keep up
with so I'm kind of hoping that you
can learn something from this
tip that really it's better
off if you get the weeds before they get
out of
control now there's other ways you can
do this it's a little bit
faster sometimes I use the other methods
sometimes I come out here with a hoe and
I basically just smack the ground where
there's a weed at to uproot it what
you'll find sometimes though is you'll
pull these weeds and if you pull them
out roots and
all they'll actually if like it's
supposed to rain later
today
so if I pull it out roots and all and
toss it on the ground you can see some
old weeds right there but if I toss them
on the ground what'll happen is it'll
rain tonight and
they'll root
again you see that happen quite a bit
you can see like a weed that's knocked
over
and I've already done a lot of this up
here but literally I can do this whole
garden almost in 10 minutes because
there's just not a
lot and uh that just makes it very quick
to walk through here and just pull
whatever weeds I
see and to be honest with you I haven't
actually done this in about 3 or 4 days
cuz you don't don't have to do it every
day you might initially like if you're
already behind on
weeding spend about 10 minutes every day
just knock a section out and then by the
time that you get the whole garden
done there shouldn't be near as many
weeds the second time and if you just
keep doing that it gets to be really
easy to take care
of you don't have to deal with going out
there and spending all day Saturday and
Sunday and
you're also by doing this every day a
little bit of time every day in the
garden you're also better able to keep
track of any type of bug or pest issues
that you might have coming up you'll
have to deal
with cuz you can you can see it way
easier when there's less weeds for
one and also you're spending more time
out in the garden which is good
for the so I guess I mean it's good for
your mental health and soul
and but you can see it's just this goes
really
fast because there's just not a lot to
mess
with now I'm actually getting ready to
Tew up this place right here where I'm
pulling these weeds I technically don't
even have to pull these weeds I'm
getting ready to till it I've got some
uh sweet potato it needs
planted and I need to heal my potatoes
the second time I put a video up a few
days ago about healing potatoes and I
need to come out here and do it the
second time to get them under control
cuz we've had so much rain again it's
supposed to rain again today
so now this is one area over here that I
did kind of let go on the
weeds that's uh carrots and peas and
I'll just be honest with you it rained
so much I couldn't get in in here so by
the time I could get in here they're
just about pretty bad shape but anyways
I thought I'd give you this tip how to
keep weeds under control in the garden
just do a little bit each day if you do
a little bit each day I mean I've
probably only been out here for however
long this video is already weeded this
area already weeded this already weeded
all that already weeded all
this and uh it'll be good now for 3 or 4
days and then I can focus on getting
these rows the next time and uh maybe
over here to the tomatoes and peppers
which they're not in that bad of shape
right
now if you saw the onions last week
before I weeded it they were in just as
bad as those carrots but they're looking
pretty good
again so they actually need some of
those need harvested I need to plant
some more but uh yeah so you can kind of
see I haven't done this in probably a
week and there's just hardly no weeds in
here even though we've had so much rain
I mean there's one every now and
then but it's not like they're not
taking over the garden right that's kind
of the point I'm trying to make if you
spend just a little bit of time each day
they won't take over your
garden
versus if you don't spend a little bit
of time each day and you just let it
take over your garden by the time you
realize that the garden needs weeded
it's a whole lot of work that you're
probably going to get frustrated with
and not complete in one
day so then it's never going to get done
it's never going to stay caught up it's
always just going to be a
mess so uh anyways I'm not going to keep
you any longer thanks for watching as
always God bless you God bless your
families God bless your
homesteads for